But the level of love that has been shown is outrageous.
Me. Okay, they sent my daughter a cup,
and this one's better because the handle is soft.
It does come with the regular heart handle,
but this one has the soft handle.
And it's an ombre pink and a sparkly,
and it still has the same.
And I don't know if the other one had this.
I wasn't paying attention.
You can also open here and,
like, you know,
she can practice learning how to drink.
You know, pour it,
lift it back and drink.
So there is good in the world.
There are good companies like gnocchi.
If you wanna buy one,
the link is right here.
It is wonderful to support companies that,
you know, look out for people.
I'm so thankful.
This cup is awesome.
I'm so excited.